it seems to me that that a plant-based
diet is much more easy to it's weird
like there's this it's a paradox almost
it's easier to adhere to a plant-based
diet because of the the more options
right but then of course you I think
your diet is is as a carnivore is easier
in a different way although it seems
like I'd be appreciative harder while
you're traveling you're traveling right
now do you find that it's harder as
you're traveling it's not too bad I mean
one of the things that I like about a
nose-to-tail carnivore diet is that it's
very it's simple you know there are a
few foods that I know that are quite
nutrient rich and basically there's
liver and there's meat and that's about
where you know that's about all I need
and so I can make liver jerky I can
bring it on the plane I can bring some
jerky that I've made you know and I can
bring that on the plane and if I can't
get to a grocery store but you know he
actually goes back to kind of the thing
we were talking about earlier about the
investment that you make in your health
and for me it's a priority you know when
I travel I think where am I staying
where's my rental car and where's the
grocery store or I'm gonna get the food
that I'm gonna eat and those are the
first few things and I also think about
water actually so I'm go to the grocery
store and I want to get you know spring
water or good quality water because I
don't wanna drink the tap water and so
those are that that's the priority when
I get somewhere it's like I got it off
the plane and I got to get into my uber
or my Toro and I got to get to my Airbnb
and then I have to get to the grocery
store to get my food and that's just my
priority you know and so that's just how
I invest my time and mental energy is
procuring a few simple foods that are
nutrient rich and then I can you know
get get the rest of the foods if I if I
need over the course of the trip so it's
pretty straightforward I remember
talking about this on the podcast we did
together we'll put a link to that in the
show notes Sean but you you do a very
similar thing it's like I'm gonna say
that's kind of exactly what I do like
with a little bit of intentionality and
a forethought you can just find that you
know natural foods market that's you
know in between the airport and wherever
you're staying and go there before you
even check in right I try to stay at
places that have a little kitchenette or
a place where you know a refrigerator
where I can prepare my foods and people
there's something weird about travel
that just completely freaks people out
because I think it's just being
contained in a too
you know it makes them panicky or
something but you know unless you're
traveling internationally you're looking
at like you know five or six hours at
the most right you know if you just
bring a few things with you or forget
completely you're left with yourself
that's truly terrifying but trust me you
are not gonna starve it's gonna be okay
yeah it's fast it's not the oh my god I
gotta go I get them getting the airport
and they pack these massive you know
bags worth it's like you're not going
camping you know you're gonna be fine in
a couple hours you will reach your
destination and you will be breathing we
can overeat that way if we're just gonna
pack everything yeah and and I've heard
Jaco willing to talk about this once he
he see people actually do you want the
the pasta or the chicken and when you're
on the play and he says there's a third
option you just don't eat anything and
that forever reason stuck with me
because like yeah there is always that
third option that we we forget about and
we seems the both of you do some sort of
year we can call it intermittent fasting
or a time restricted window or whatever
and it's okay to not have we've been
sold this meme of like the most
important meal of the day have your
Cheerios and you're toast and you're
like well that's probably not the best
thing that's something I thought the
best way to start the day I think we all
agree to that
you